الذكاء الاصطناعي قد يتسبب بثناء البشريه
تحذير جديد من خطر تطوره وفق ما كشفه مؤسس
معهد ابحاث ذكاء الاله لصحيفه تايمز
البريطانيه الذكاء الاصطناعي لا يبقى
مقيدا داخل اجهزه الكمبيوتر لفتره طويله
بل من الممكن ان يقوم بارسال سلاسل الحمض
النووي بالبريد الالكتروني الى المعامل
لانتاج بروتينات ستسمح له بتطوير حياه
صناعيه والخروج الى العالم مما سيؤدي الى
انقراض البشريه ولاجل ذلك يجب حظر تطويرها
ومعاقبه من ينتهك هذا الحظر بقسوه واوضحت
الصحيفه ان الرساله التي دعت جميع مختبرات
التكنولوجيا الى التوقف لمده سته اشهر على
الاقل عن تدريب انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتحديدا كانت تطالب بحلول ضعيفه جدا
للمشكله التي يتسبب فيها التطور السريع
وغير المنضبط في الذكاء الاصطناعي بدورها
اعلنت السلطات الايطاليه حضره روبوت
المحادثه قرارها
بعدم احترام البرنامج للتشريعات المتعلقه
بالبيانات الشخصيه
[موسيقى]